[Music]
and snorkeling souvenir news submitted
by sharp limelight a man was arrested in
Turkey over coins he fell in Falls north
wing were they illegal illegal coins or
something was he smart looking in a
fountain crazy man the coins belong to
the country
not like a historical thing you're not
supposed to remove anything so this man
you should have kissed her those coins
Toby he's 52 years old from the UK oh
look a suit yeah yeah he looks like he
teaches algebra oh yeah but in a funny
way what kind of boys that he fine um so
some historic Alcorn's I've got there in
a second so he was with this family
vacationing in Turkey is up really he
went snorkeling and near these islands
where you snorkels there had been an
earthquake like two weeks prior to when
he went snorkeling and they're saying
that the earthquake might've liked
shuffled things around because there had
been because there had been a lot of
shipwrecks from cool like centuries ago
oh so cool yeah and so he's not so Toby
found 13 gold coins Oh God so he was
gonna take them home as a souvenir and
so when he was at the airport the
airport police say they discovered that
he had these gold coins and they said
that they were like artifacts from the
country and I was illegal with the
punishment up to three years and how he
posts to know though no that's why it's
making them use because it's like that's
not fair they should buy it off he's not
some [ __ ] smuggler yeah his family's
saying like he's not a smuggler you just
go snorkeling on it off him they should
thank him for finding such like
artifacts and [ __ ] and donates in
museums and [ __ ] like be you're welcome
for finding shipwrecks for you [ __ ]
yeah they should just be like hey this
is cool you found this as a token of our
appreciation we're gonna give you
something else well pretty quick flight
back or May
he could keep one of the 13 coins me 13
that's uh leave them with one I found on
Finders Keepers yeah and so now he's
being held in prison
oh sorry really sucks they don't even
tell his family like how long he's gonna
be there or like what's gonna happen is
malicious that's so sad you're just more
clinging and you're like oh I found some
buried treasure
and then the next thing you know you're
getting raped in jail you don't even
know it's buried treasure you're like oh
cool I found something cool and for all
you know it's fake I feel like I would
not tell the government if I found it
I'd be like yeah it's bad just like yeah
I'll be like this is treasure I would
have just been like this is I bought it
off a [ __ ] souvenir street vendor
yeah he put on his carry-on yeah cause
you'd probably like I had value to him
and then his price so honest where you
got to fill out like that customs form
that's one thing he didn't he didn't
declare it no he didn't no how did he
know that it was even gonna be worth
anything so I don't know I don't think
there's any foul play exactly yeah how
did they find it it's just when they
were searching his hand luggage they
found it that's not fair he's like next
to like a heroin smuggler and some
[ __ ] child touchers and like burglars
and [ __ ] he's like the algebra teacher
just hanging out like put to [ __ ] I
could picture him in a holding cell like
all scared what did you do I'm cooling
what if it's really bad you like you did
what you saw you do you fought out of
the prison a head honcho I don't like
hey everybody listen this guy he [ __ ]
didn't turn in artifacts
everyone's like oh [ __ ] down this guy's
crazy yeah but it's pretty cool they're
saying that there had been about 25
shipwrecks from 4th to 6th centuries all
in that area
yeah and that area what was happening
when you need to go snorkeling of that
layer you're healed no it's like there's
island it's just the turkey Aylin huh I
always wanted because he's so he didn't
scuba right he'll snorkeling so that's
how easier what it's fun to find that
kind of stuff then he found it among
like rocks and stuff the old capital of
the Eastern Roman Empire was in
Alexandra Istanbul ah something like
that land of Turkey where all the
turkeys live yep
did you know a Turkish dumpling it's
called a king Klee no but what's in a
Turkish dumpling so I was I follow these
Russian powerlifters and two of these
guys are eating these funny-looking
dumplings on a plate and I saw them and
I'm like oh [ __ ] what the hell does look
just like Shalom bowels except they're
huge
you're not shuttling bars like this big
yeah each one of these were like this
big like a chassis ha ha yeah but it was
uh it was uh it was twisted on a top
like oh no it's not it's a dumpling
though it's not about it's actually
dumpling and I'm like what the [ __ ] is
that and I was reading in between the
Russian and then it said kink Li it's
like Google there it's a dumpling that
originated in Georgia but it's a Turkish
dumpling what if that came to the Silk
Route and the Chinese people made it
their own style it could have been and
then I started researching all the
dumplings of the world and so there's
mon Dieu love Korea there's Monte of
like the Middle East and then I did all
this this morning actually you know I
was like man I don't know I want to try
I want to go on a quest and eat all the
dumplings of the world like from Rocky -
ravioli - all that stuff that's true
that's how I navigate the websites
because sometimes I'm like on Instagram
and I'm all I don't know what this is
what are you blowing it
like i'm scrolling yeah i'm michael and
i get i get i get curious like what what
is this so-called turkish coffee
what is this thing I never had one of
these and you go down the rabbit hole
yeah I'll type it in Turkish coffee and
then I get to learn about all these
things and I'm like dad that's crazy
and then cut to like four hours later
Jess I'm gonna start growing coffee
pieces now I'm gonna tell him you're
done or like he's dumb and then he's
gonna get angry for not supporting his
dream why he was crushing my dreams
there's this one thing I found though I
was like mmhmm it's a Nepalese dumpling
and it has meat and then there's a
tomato sauce that goes inside the
dumpling this is like ketchup dumpling
oh man we need to go on a dumpling
question we gotta go a dumpling tour I
love dumplings
I love deep fried dumplings people
should deep-fry them more fries them
right now Japanese people are Korea
people get a man dude have you seen
those yeah Korean dumplings they're like
a half circle yeah yeah and then you
deep-fry that whole [ __ ] and it
comes out looking like I got a million
blisters issue is so good I see you some
that are pan-fried - oh man I could eat
dumplings all day oh you guys travel
around like especially going to Hawaiian
stuff do you ever find anything and you
keep it like part of it like I don't
have anything from Hawaii no it's only
legal I don't have anything from the
beaches of Hawaii no because if you do
the spirits of Hawaii especially the
lava rocks gonna [ __ ] kill you you
can't touch their lava rock you got a
lot better I don't have
I don't have any dead coral that I found
off the beach that I took home doing
I think corals okay it's just
biologically irresponsible I didn't find
a lot is wrong with you of dead coral
and I did not take home a little piece
that look like a cactus what's it what's
a Mexican version don't lay empanada oh
that's not Mexicans
that's what dumpling well we don't use
that's a lot of Latin based ones no no
there was Cuban empanadas there's
there's a better way to sing it the
Hmong actually give you a [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
not really a dumpling you guys have
anything yeah we have like there's a
steamed ones that you pork your sauce
over now we have a lot actually we don't
have [ __ ] you dumped this I don't think
so
they probably do but they don't eat
foods so they don't know I just want to
travel and see landmarks and eat food
that's all I care about like I'll go to
different countries and I'll be like
take me to your [ __ ] food and
now Casey and I had a really short time
in Istanbul like we did an overnight
layover and when we were there we really
wanted to try like the local food for
real tinkly yeah but we only had like
two hours to really explore so we just
ended up going the beach and said nice
big you got to go outside the airport oh
yeah we were staying in a hotel
there's no all right man I want to
travel more
I got to see shells that's I was asking
you guys because I can't believe hey
what's up guys thanks for watching we
are going to regularly start posting
content on the JK films Instagram so
make sure you follow us there the last
video click over here
[Music]